jetzt bin ich gerade
okay halt s maul der freuen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem video ist schon
so spät es ist einfach schon acht uhr
aber ich habe wirklich den ganzen tag am
buch gearbeitet und wir haben sehr sehr
viel geschafft und da bin ich richtig
stolz darauf ihr alter und ihre leute
waren sehr interessiert an diesem buch
und fast immer damit meine bitte mit ab
daran arbeiten und das weiß ich wir
machen immer die haben ja sonst kriegt
alles mögliche wie das ganze gut basiert
auf welcher seite war steht und so das
haben wir und wir haben jetzt auch noch
was jetzt letztens hingekriegt haben
sind schon samson papierseiten dies
träge aussehen wird das haben wir halt
auch noch gemacht und als b2b freunde
herzlich willkommen hier am montag ab es
ist donnerstag ist ja auch komplett egal
ich habe mir einfach gedacht dass ich
heute am donnerstagabend anstatt gaming
oder irgendwie sowas mal endlich mal
wieder fragen von später beantwortet
weil der letzter zeit welche mega viele
leute mich zu allen möglichen themen was
fragen habe ich mir gedacht beantworte
ich das doch mal was fragt was würdest
du eine plattform youtube ändern an sich
gefällt mir die plattform mega gut ich
denke ich würde nichts dran ändern außer
die blöde lange verarbeitungszeit anna
fragt ob ich kochen kann also wenn ihr
euch mal meinen schrank anschaut dann
ist das einzige was da drin ist in
welche dosen krams thunfisch nutella
ganz viel nudeln
ja ich brauche nur scheiße und wenn man
sich mal meinen kühlschrank anschaut ist
das ganze halt auch nicht so voller sie
da sind noch ein paar essensreste und
sonst ist er halt echt nicht so viel
drin
also ich möchte nicht lügen ich sage
einfach ich kann überhaupt nicht kochen
ich kann das kochen was ich selber gerne
esse also spaghetti reis gemüse so was
in die richtung aber an sich kann ich
mich ein
ich bin noch gar nicht daran
interessiert dass irgendwie groß lernen
zu müssen wie kochen oder so weil ich
hab halt das privileg dass sehr viele
coole restaurant sehr günstigen
restaurants in der nähe sind und es ist
teilweise den restaurants schon
günstiger das essen als wenn ich im
supermarkt zusammen kaufen würde selber
kochen würde dann müsste ich es ja auch
noch kochen und saubermacher blatt
plötzlich alles albi frage würdest du
wollen dass seine kinder deine videos in
der zukunft sehen würden oder deinen
kanal deswegen löschen
erste gute frage
während überlege was ich war schon als
wir uns wieder zusammen
denn ich denke dass ich die videos nicht
löschen werde weil natürlich kann es
später sein dass ich mich nicht mehr mit
den videos identifizieren kann oder so
aber einer gewissen form bildet das teil
meines lebens deswegen denke ich nicht
dass ich die videos löschen werde auch
bei mir später meine kinder sagen wer
nun hat er gemerkt würdest du dir die
haare bunt oder braun schwarz blond
färben
ich hasse leute die sich die haare
färben also die leute an sich kein mega
korrekt sein aber ich verstehe nicht
wieso man sich die haare fährt nicht
wenn man sollte mit dem zufrieden sein
was man hat und wenn man sich das ändern
möchte auch okay aber ich mag sorry
falls ich fertig aus der ich hatte drei
stunden schlaf klopp das sieht man mir
an was du noch kuscheltiere von früher
wenn ja kannst du sie zeigen einem ich
hab hier gerade keine meiner wohnung ich
habe zu hause noch welche aber auch nur
einen teddybär glücklich sondern ich
hatte meinem großen braun teddybär so
ganz typical mäßig ist gar nicht nett
das heißt haustier so ganz ganz ganz
typisch stofftier sich einfach einen
großen braunen teddybär hat sich casey
fragt welche fernsehsendungen hast du
als kind gerne geschaut
pokémon pokémon ina fragt ob ich die
briefe vom video der schon gelesen
bisschen besser ausgepackt habe ja ich
hab alles ausgepackt und auch schon
alles gelesen und auch die ganze
süßigkeiten getränke die ich bekommen
habe getrunken gegessen
danke für alles sina fragt was auf
meinem grabstein stehen soll
ich möchte das auf meinem grabstein
irgendwas fröhliches steht und nicht so
was wie er war für uns dass und erwarte
hieß und rest in peace und und blabla
ich möchte dass da irgendwas fröhliche
steht sodass man hergeht und irgendwie
schmunzeln muss oder dass
er geht mit einem lächeln und nicht
traurig ist das ja auch schon mal gesagt
dass ich möchte das auf meiner
beerdigung fröhliche musik gespielt wird
nicht dieses gedudelt einfach so jurak
so fragt wenn die möglichkeit ist den
ganzen wenn du die möglichkeit hat ist
der ganzen welt etwas zu sagen wie das
wenn du die möglichkeit hast der ganzen
welt etwas zu sagen was würdest du sagen
ich habe mega hunger gerade träumerin
frage wärst du lieber eine pizza kotzen
das einhorn oder einen regenbogen wird
da hat okay ich hab die auswahl zwischen
pizza kotzen das anhören oder regenbogen
pupsen des einhorn in dem regenbogen
pupsen loris fragt ob ich bei wago drei
mitmachen werde ich bisher noch keinen
nachwuchs bekommen allerdings werden die
auch raus geschickt und soll ja die
gleichen leute gehen lieber 21 dabei
waren das heißt ich denke ich werde
darauf eingeladen zu werden tun sein ich
will mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht
sicher ob ich mitmachen werde also ich
denke zwar eigentlich schon allerdings
bin ich derzeit wirklich nicht so viel
an minecraft spielen muss ich ganz
ehrlich zugeben ich war halt auch bei
diesem ganzen war events bisher nie
wirklich gut deswegen ich denke ich
damit machen aber ich werde nicht lange
bitten
das ist nicht wenn fällt wie stehst du
zum thema cybermobbing
ich denke jeder steht sehr negativ dort
dem was ich glaube keiner die
befürworter von cybermobbing und ich
finds auch einfach feige wenn man so was
macht also für mich im winter leute die
sowas machen einfach keine menschen
michelle fragt hast du deine
hausaufgaben nicht mal abgeschrieben
oder her selbst gemacht beides markus
fragt wer gewinnt den dfb-pokal der vfl
kommerz burg seid mal schnitzel fragt
wie viele tage produzierst du immer so
vor der zeit bin ich nur ein paar
produzieren es gibt es nahezu keine
videos mehr die hochgeladen werden die
ich an dem tag aufgenommen habe jetzt
bin ich gerade
okay halt s maul jetzt bin ich gerade
wieder an vorproduzieren für bis
mittwoch weil ich dann erst wieder hier
bin und danach werde ich auch wieder
voll produzieren weil die uni wieder
losgeht nicht auch noch eine klausur
schreiben freitag ist ein bisschen
stressig ja das war's mit fragen
beantwortet ob es hat euch gefallen ich
hoffe eure frage wird im video mit
beantwortet oder so wenn es euch gefällt
natürlich mich meine bewertung freuen
oder ein abonnement oder was weiß ich ja
heute bei twitter facebook instagram und
alle sozialen netzwerken klickt auf die
werbung und dann sehen wir uns
irgendwann später wieder chips